JIM WALDO: Do you know how
to ethically collect and use
personal data for your business?
By gathering this data, you
have taken on a responsibility
to protect the privacy of
those whose data you gather.
In data privacy and
technology, we will consider
the many definitions of privacy and
their implications for individuals,
corporations, and governments.
We will explore what personal privacy
means, how data is collected and used,
the trade-offs between privacy and
other values, and look to the future.
ANDY YEN: Your data can
and will outlive you.
It will be there forever.
It just seems ridiculous to not try
to protect this most valuable asset.
MIKE SMITH: This course
is crucial for businesses
today because of the
changing nature of our world.
You will immerse yourself in
real-world challenges faced
by industry-leading experts, and explore
the legal and ethical implications
of collecting user and customer data.
ALASTAIR MACTAGGART: When you
think about it in a larger sense,
our personal information really is
the fuel for these corporations.
LATANYA SWEENEY: There are just
so many different interests
in so many different issues.
It's not just how do I
deliver anonymous data.
MIKE SMITH: Privacy is a complex
and multifaceted concept.
By the end of the course,
you should be able to apply
your learning to your life,
your role, and your business.
It's time to learn how to
balance the utility of a data set
with the privacy of the individuals.
Do you agree to enroll in this course?
[MUSIC PLAYING]